right and we are live last point is back
why this how you doing - a pretty good
man doing pretty good we are on the eve
of war mines so not the equine where our
best thing I will say because our next
one we're gonna have to pull ourselves a
way to try and get you Miller I've got
some things to be positive about and I
think a lot of what we're seeing here if
this isn't the one that quite does it
for you it's still gonna be one that
sets up the fall to be where we want it
to be to have that chance and it's ugly
you couldn't have said it any better I
think this is the the set up to hold
oddly okay I think this is a perfect
setup you know - uh what we what we
anticipate might be even greater in
September so I am excited I am a lot to
talk about and some crucible action I've
been getting into we'll talk about that
- all right well you want to jump into
the crucible since that's what we at
least got going on right now I know I
was gonna ask what you've been playing
but I know you've been playing Iron Man
or like looking at man yeah man I mean
the whole plan was to kind of do what
you were doing which was to kind of get
God of War done and then because I'm
obsessive-compulsive I found out about
the iron banner ornaments going away and
I really enjoyed iron banner since it's
been back in the six weeks ago I'm like
is it's the closest thing to D 1 it's so
much fun you know and on top of it just
not not even just a sixes it's actually
you know what it is for me it's the
actual heavy dropping as well from
killed enemies so if you have a skilled
hand you're killing people they drop
their heavy you're getting more heavy so
it's just it's just fun and then um like
I said I've been running the Warlock
I've got everything but the damn chess
piece which requires only mainly in
grenade kills and other
little grand man oh it's brutal and then
what sucks is I got I'm very jealous of
you hunters you guys can you know rock
what is it strider and that's counting
as a melee when you need super now storm
yeah
yes don't quickly used to count not
anymore
didn't say because they changed it
because i remember there was an exotic
we got the karnsteins not to but
lightning tickling is not a melee hey
man i'm using my hands just like okay
this is gonna be a grind I got to change
my complete build to just get more you
know melee and um grenade kills and it's
just been just trying to find that right
battles right now I'm running a
phidian's I'm running um for a void and
I'm doing accion I'm doing that catch
archetype accion's whenever I see a
group I'm just tossing it they're kind
of bit but in my travels that's the only
good thing about all this grinding I
gotta do um is that but I think maybe
two or three class points before I told
you about um the time war inspire right
like that's the post a job for me post
you know I'm doing fairly well against
vigilance I mean vigilance is still
dominating out there however I got Sally
Lord Saladin blessed me with this thing
dropped master work it's called the um
I'm like always wouldn't know it's weird
no it's um only once that I gotta get
your name on this thing man these things
is be time open up my I didn't manage
them right now I'm giving all the Lords
everybody's listening the flashpoint a
little trick a little help right now
here or Aman's and Phil oh boy this
thing is an auto rifle that's acting
like a scout in hits like a truck
the range is it's like 86 range and I
got a master work with a range boost
nice this
right now it feels like I feel bad what
I'm doing the people my k/d right now I
like to point something three points
it's disgusting
and remember I have to I have to
literally play not to win because I'm
killing people too fast from distance
and I need to get the mail like put
order of it so that was you first world
problems right there no I had to tow
more skill down I think I have that on
PlayStation I'm literally looking at
destiny item and right now because I
know I have it on one of these and I'm
looking at when yeah where is it because
I swear I've got that gun cuz I'm out Oh
Nora means anvil who's the one that
built the first Forge I'm gonna tell you
right now that is disgusting that the
vendor right now right and it's the same
archetype as origin story but way more
rage that's that for 50 rpm dude I'm
having a blast I'm having so much fun
with it and I can't stop playing
crucible so that's what I've been doing
with it
I have been playing a lot of gotta war
trying to grind through it as much as I
can before all the craziness happens
next week yes and it still continues
though just improve as I go the more you
level up your character the more your
combat can change the more you can adapt
the set piece that I got - last night
when I was playing and that's why I was
up for way too late he was up late like
1:30 was like I gotta go to bed and I
was like I know you're up but I
shouldn't be oh he's blazing so but it
was and I've still been playing like
probably a lot more exploration than I
should to explore but I don't want to
miss anything I'm going to literally
find every chest if you're looking for
certain pieces I literally I got my full
health bar last night like um but the
set piece I hit last night you hear as
the as you're going lawn Lord gets
dropped in a couple different ways so
you're getting information story about
all of the Norse mythology and stuff
like that and then there's a piece that
and they talk about the scale of
something and while I'd seen something
big this one was just another pursuit
just the scale of what I saw is just
like oh my goodness
trying to keep him clean my words were
probably a little different than that it
really was awesome to see and yeah just
kind of what you were doing with it the
scale of just the whole encounter and
section still still awesome and the
combat keeps getting better because as I
was I even texted you about this as well
as I was playing there are encounters in
that game that will treat you like a but
Dark Souls boss fight because if you
find a level but if you find it anything
that is over your level it is a beating
and they will one shot you now and
you're good you could take them cuz I've
literally got about half health down and
then I like blip for a second you die
but it's like if you wanted to really
practice and like hone your skills take
those type of fights I've seen you can
work on getting better it's like alright
wait for it wait for it okay and dodge
it's like wait Kay dodge this way okay
get a shot swings that pullback it's
like but now I've got the point where at
Reyes is doing stuff he's helping stunts
he's throwing errors well I've got
different axe attacks I'm dodging
there's so much going on for combat if
you ever worry if it starts a little a
little tame it gets so much fun so and I
think that is the type of thing one of
those things I'd like to see in dusty is
those enemies that will literally just
if you're going along and we'll
hopefully get there just be like yeah
just shut it down comeback editor yeah
well they did say to implement in the
also those guys are like the old d1 days
with a crushing walk over your head over
their heads so was it yeah you see a
question marker has a skull for a level
number and you're like aw crap no been
enjoying that one but I'm also excited
about this so we are not far guys mm-hmm
it's May 4th may the 4th be with all of
you for those Star Wars fans out there
because you're so low you can go get
your solo tickets today apparently but
May 8th we've got the world drop and
it's gonna be it seems like about
they said 11 a.m. Pacific time is when
it is supposed to go live can I say for
the record I don't like the new risk it
researchers get over that outdated
universe that I hate I miss the old
reset 3 a.m. 4 a.m. yeah at least where
that K well I'm selfishly you know work
nights but it's like on the East Coast
lease in the morning if you were there
or even if it was a big deal see you
want you took off work alright
you love minute I got the whole day like
this I understand they doing it for a
global reach thing I get it but have
really miss do time yeah I do and I
don't I do for a point of like yeah if
something went live I know I'd have time
to play it no matter what I did for work
now it's typically in the middle of work
but if I make videos I'm not waking up
at 3 o'clock in the morning off my
normal schedule twice a week yeah sure
so I was setting alarm at 3 o'clock in
the morning and I'm like I'm still a
normal somewhat daylight person so yeah
it's it has its ups and downs like
content creators probably enjoy it for
some extent but it's like yeah I could
understand like you don't get my 21 hour
gaming session in one day cuz release
was a three I'm like if I was a day
since their son but yeah they've got it
they've got a time so servers are gonna
be down pretty early I think it was like
6 or 7 a and they're gonna kick
everybody off download will be going and
then patch notes will be come in about
an hour before it goes up and then about
1:00 p.m. for me 2 p.m. for you so 1
p.m. Central 2 p.m. eastern eleven a m--
pacific is when it is supposed to go
live and I'm going to work the morning
shift so I'm already gonna be tired but
I will be playing all night so I'll be
off at about 2:00 so I'll be jumping on
pretty quick the opposite soon as I'm
like literally on my fly home for my
night shift
go to bed immediately chatting at least
4 to 5 hours
they didn't minute that suck of those
laughs and I gotta touch it man they're
Eva the diva has returned well sir why
has the fever returned what has gotten
what has planted that bug
it's just a combination things but I
mean like I said I mean we talked about
this many flats place before II and this
is I'm more I know people that the
hardcore I mean the casuals they like
you know the story the new expansion
raid or whatever whatever and that's
great I'm excited for that stuff but um
it's the system's man the I'm a systems
guy I'm the guy but we always talk from
day one if you give me sandbox updates
and things like that consistently it's
like a new game to me every time and I'm
gonna type I'm such meticulous with the
minutiae that I want to test everything
out you know and when I when I hear
these kind of things and we'll get into
it you know more with the exotic maximum
changes and all other things they're
doing and you know in the be honest like
I've really renewed with crucible
because sixes I've been back with
brainer and I'm excited for that now we
know fours you still to do the UM the
glory which we will touch him you know
it's just getting myself in that mental
competitive space for crucible so that
when it hits cuz I'm gonna love you your
boy trying to get that glory reason for
that along with you and everybody else
that's it'll stick out there but they've
been missing that and a lot of people
want to get so that's the old destiny I
miss I miss walking into it I'll never
forget it and your boy got that oh man
that was a brutal change for what good
is I was like yeah you see me melted it
just drove them enroll people a trial so
that they could try give a shot at that
gun you know and I think that's what
rhetorics which we'll get into
represents yeah yeah so we've got a lot
of stuff coming Bungie has been active
on the just info dumps kind of
everywhere but actually I'm pleasantly
surprised is not too much yes
so far it's been a right balance they
haven't shown too much they have some
teases in a couple places which is nice
I'm hoping one major tease that I caught
yesterday is not too much
you know what I'm talking about it's to
scale you know see the scale yeah yeah
but I think they've done fairly well
trying to get people hyped up give give
them reasons to come back now for those
of you guys that played B want like D to
vanilla stopped that was just wasn't
your thing is this the thing that is
your game changer for you what do you
think me somewhat yes but it may not be
the true game changer some people want
do I think it's definitely better than
curse of Osiris before he been touching
it I do oh absolutely I would have to
bet it's definitely better yes they've
learned they've heard the feedback
they're like the mercury circle you know
I don't need my cul-de-sac on mercury
I've even seen some interviews were
there like yeah mercury was too small
like they have you if the sparrows not
there you know it's - I know they try to
create artificial space but it's the I
don't know if it was just because I mean
mercury is a small planet in general but
I know Mercury's bigger than the circle
so they only had one landing zone they
didn't take the infinite forest was
supposed to be a big thing with
adventures but they just didn't lie said
enough if they that lets you go let me
pop in and like run through the little
tunnel and see which part of the
infinite of course I pop into and then
if you go do some random thing at the
end you can even come back out like if
you could do that that would open that
space up more but they just did not
utilize your dad DLC breaks my heart man
because that's my favorite character and
it's the thing about it that sucks -
it's like you said they're potentially
infinite forests the things that they
could have done want to end on top of it
is be that it's my favorite like the
whole I love mercury I love the
lighthouse hours more and to know that's
it
being gone back there you know that's it
like you know it just sucks that it did
I almost wish Curtis Knox could get a
do-over or a remake or just
functionality to it so you can still
come back to it to do other things it's
just a shame a shame yeah I know so well
we have our fingers crossed we know Anna
Bray of the Clovis Bray facility is
going to be your main point of contact
we saw that last week with the kind of
reveal and such oh I've got new things
and we'll kind of go through these in
pieces or
this week at Bungie first sorry for the
50 15 minute introduction this way I've
got this week at Bungie we'll go into
the season three which is a different
page the warm line page will cover those
kind of separately but we'll just talk
about everything as we go mm-hmm
so as you guys can see here we're
looking at first just the top of this
week at Bungie and they're not that far
counting them down basically down to
days and they said cheers the Vicarious
Visions they seem to be kind of almost
code developing this at this point to a
point where bungees really really got
them deep involved with the development
seems like that ideas on bosses and
things when you hear speaking of the
scale they're just saying hey we want a
giant boss fight and Vicarious Visions
kind of push for that and they actually
got a little bit of you know help in the
development of this expansion which is
cool
I mean I'm I played on PC props to those
guys because they took the feel of a
game that is great on console like and
it feels the same on PC to me I it's
hard for me to go back to console just
because it's smooth but no it was like
but they have that big have to feel the
feel and they got it that's one look at
the clips
it looks fantastic and I was like it
looks amazing yeah so it's one of those
things hats off to those guys so if
they're involved in this at least we
know the PC will continue to be
hopefully a good place if they can win
some of those players back it's gonna
take some work because pc players hazey
have even more to play than console but
like in one aback they got a good group
so they're just happy about it they're
happy to be part of it so on approach we
got a lot of things drop so we had the
narrative preview which came from a few
pieces let me see if I can find the
right tab here so we've got the
narrative preview and actually gave us
the warmind comic so if you guys have
read the comic do what I said oh joy
now thoughts of a comic aside because we
have been through this before so it's
like we had Osiris we had a comic and we
got a backstory we're like okay and then
we got our expansion and we were let
down so what are your thoughts about
well thanks to our offline reading with
Yvonne says they would educate me
because I did not read this comment for
certain reasons but all right in total
finish this story is way better then um
because Osiris comic book the tone is
better it's a nice setup I mean I can't
take anything away from it however my
lovely rant I'll try to make it short is
this I struggle with this kind of stuff
because you know from a law from the law
community I like it they're trying to
pay attention to the lore and trying to
give it service and be a little bit more
serious with it but at the same time
it's like to put it in the game like
like only the hardcore of the hardcore
are going to like us you know we the
table and you know we'll get into what I
sector will be she ate this kind of
thing but the cashew is not doing this
right the casual doesn't even know
probably this comic exists and it's a
shame so it's like maybe they should
take off put the comic how about there's
a section you know in in in in your
items have a section like show the
seriousness with the lore in the game
and we've been down this road with
grimoire you know I don't want to go out
of the game and again everything else
they've been doing is great I don't
really want to go too hard on them
because I do appreciate the effort and
they set it up you know it's just I
really stroll my eyes you know this
could be how cool would it be booed up
right before the dlc you know and then
you bought you know you put a destiny to
and this is in there in some form you
know I mean that would be honestly
really cool I mean it's images so I
don't see why they couldn't do it
personally I'd like to see it it'd be a
nice way to just even if it's under I
always think they feel sometimes like
they're gonna break their little
universe yes and not little I mean
they've built a pretty sizable one but
they feel like by putting a
Tomic in the game like just because
you're flipping through screenshots of
the comic I mean they're detailed images
you could look at it you could zoom but
it'll you'd be in the game spending time
in there and it's a shame because this
thing like I said I didn't read into you
know we had storytime with the brothers
before the show I did educate myself you
know it gives you an idea of what she
was doing during the whole red Legion or
red war and all that you know she seems
like a very cool I really don't know
enough about shout to the Lord masses
myelin and bite you know I really don't
know a lot about her to be honest when I
saw the trail the trail of dope I like
the whole you know she's had the robotic
eyes I liked her the family history as
far as what they've done you know as far
as even the things that they've created
it is just like I said it would be just
cool to you know pay that off in the
game I just want more Bungie to do a
little bit more of that and we'll get
into that later when it comes to a ray
later I have some comments on that as
well yep so it's a pretty decent little
comment guys you should check it out
it's just kind of a little blip it
beaten they kind of leave you at a bit
of a cliffhanger so maybe we'll get more
when the story starts next week or
they're gonna do a second piece I don't
know if they're gonna space it out give
you a little bit more as we go but it's
kind of like the idea you get a little
bit behind her there's still some
questions they there are some questions
as you read through and you don't get
all the answers so if you want you know
completely wrapping this thing up you're
gonna be left with some questions but
awesome art nice nice job as always
absolutely now there's other pieces I'm
not gonna go through a marina mall I'm
gonna slowly pan through these on screen
yeah basically they had lower tabs
little sections little blips about a
couple characters so if you guys want to
go on bungie.net
and read these it's gonna be kind of on
all this you know narrative stuff they
had going on and you guys can see they
had like so tyra carne so you've got she
was the one at the top of our snowy
mountain before and she's got some
little comments here discussion back and
forth with a ghost
and then you've got Apocrypha
yeah but that looks like the picture we
keep seeing of like the hive boss we're
fighting mm-hmm box a bit about the
worms there's different worms there's
all which we've heard about so there are
all those things so it goes into some
hive lore and you've got to talk about
the cryptarch which we all love to hate
you know man in charge up there the
beast with the best shoulder armor in
the game yes sir and then you've got
rasputin's little blip here just from
himself more of his discussion now this
is for everybody just the fact that it's
there though is pretty cool I liked
respect they give you stuff to read if
you want to dig in see if there's any
like is there a code in here is there
some secret message who knows like what
is - honey TVI 800 junior as one oh and
I mean that's just you know warm I talk
it's an AI it's just numbers and stuff
but it they'll take time to do all this
sometimes so I'm a fan that stuff so
check out the lore if you guys want to
get a little reading time in if you're
sitting around you know dropping the
kids off of the pool just playing the
game I want to read however you choose
so the narrative previews cool check
them out it is a good time with the
comic and stuff so next we've got as the
week has gone on we've got developer
insights and those have been a little
bit three minute videos with regards to
just kind of thoughts behind what
develop developers are doing be it with
exotics and crucible we got that one
first so we had Josh Hamrick and Kevin
Yanis who were on the reveal stream so
they were talking about their thoughts
on exotics what they're working on for
sandbox and we've seen most of this one
before so this wasn't exactly you know
new revelations or anything but it does
look pretty cool we got a few more blips
when it comes to a couple guns as well
mm-hmm so down below we'll get to those
here in a little bit but both of those
developer insights if you want to like
get in a bit of an idea they don't go in
full detail like they probably did when
they were at the community summit they
got basically no-holds-barred questions
at the summit so they got a lot more
information little depth a little more
and honesty it sounded like so hey what
were your thoughts here this okay well
that wasn't great but thanks for at
least telling us I mean that was that
was the level of detail they got now
we're getting kind of an abbreviated
version of that but it's still nice to
see ya I'm not gonna play the videos but
you guys can see risk runner is in there
so we've got a little bit more to talk
about on that one I can't tell if it's
gonna be a major change on that one but
it doesn't yeah they're very cute I mean
I did I did watch it now remember them
saying that the arc damaged dark
resistance is increased and what I like
is that it also takes effect even when
the weapon is stowed and I like that new
thing they're doing with that stuff I
believe they doing that with Rat King
you still have the effect when it's told
and that's cool I love that that's a
great subtle change so yeah I mean I
think you have the whereas your chosen
weapon is still having the benefits if
not all so we didn't have the war mind
developer insight come out so this is
more you want to cover this one yeah I
mean this was really cool I'm trying to
remember this ones I always get them
mixed up I was I've been watching so
much Bungie stuff
I believe this one they would talk what
I talking about the different modes I
believe escalation protocol they talked
some about I want to say just kind of
the story behind it as well they know
the campaign is gonna be there but it's
more what they want the purpose of the
whole expansion to be they know the
campaign is gonna be there and they kind
of glossed over which makes me wonder
well how much maybe they just don't want
to get much way crossing fingers but
they got more into modes and things like
that so I think it was definitely major
focus on this escalation protocol yes
got the escalation protocol coming and
you know all the other stuff little
goodies afterwards so I mean like I said
I mean we got we got our story we have
our big bad so to speak we've also got
some mystery with with worms which they
showed cinematically and that looked
cool and it was good to see Soros in
there doing what it do as well as um it
also had the other healing perk back
that's actually checked on the head the
the tessaro's has besides being the
bottom half of the magazine it also has
that little chance for healing I saw
that kicking it'll be nice and some PvP
action as we get
some of the modifiers and changes we got
that'll be that'll be good but they go a
little more into just the scale of the
area that we've got
so the Hellas Basin they started talking
about kind of the contrast between the
areas that you're gonna be running
around in so you've got the caverns and
the tunnels that the hive had basically
made when all this ice basically shut
the world down mm-hmm so you've got the
caverns and the tunnels that are very
dark and snowy cold all that and they've
got the upper level where it's still
gonna be I mean they're the ice caps of
Mars but it's sandy a little brighter
it's outside they're more open so you've
got you know snowy tunnels ice tunnels
whatever with hive and then you guys
know the Machine area of the Clovis prey
facility right sounds like we've
definitely got a lot more at least at a
minimum to look to look around
so they said it was about the scale of
Titan yes it has a decent amount of
interior stuff that you don't absolutely
when you're just kind of run around the
to little outside platforms there's an
easily met inside and underneath and the
lost sector you mean that's a whole
sections you'll find anything below so
there's a decent meant to it so if it's
that size I think that at least
qualifies for an expansion it's like
it's a whole zone it feels like and I do
remember now when I was where I said
they were saying about just from the
collectible standpoint there's things to
collect their secrets now you know and
that's always cool because up until this
point you know in d2 we really haven't
had that and just seeing them talk about
that giving us more things to do more
things to search for mysteries using the
you know the the ghost and searching
different things I saw that aspect going
on and what I'm hoping for is because
like we said there was a screenshot like
someone took a still shot of the map and
we talked about this earlier anywhere
was like you know 0 or 50 whatever
collection you want to map and that
that's like old d1 stuff when you're
looking for those chests you looking for
the collectibles and what I'm hoping is
which I'm thinking they're really
hinting at is this tying to a bigger
secret arc
hopefully sleeper simulant baby your big
hope mm-hmm because I do enjoy the gun
mm-hmm but I would me I'm always for the
new
like I know sleeper you got a special
place for it right now if they had
sleeper and something else yeah then I'm
done and yes please
but I was like I don't bring it back d1
stuff like I don't want the big giant
quest at the end of the summer or
something to be like hey go get one I
don't want them to keep back which I'm
okay with because it's a fun gun but
again what if it wasn't suros being
updated what if it's something else now
maybe it's easier with some of those it
was just even slightly what if it wasn't
just an auto rifle say it was a sorrows
hand cannon with that type of thing like
yeah like a nice taste like I did with
Crimson I figure my only thing is in
this case you're completely right in
this case because everything they've
shown as a drop for escalation mode has
literally been the body style mock of
sleeper simulant like that's the oh
that's like giving out a DLC where every
gun and weapon type looks like a mini
Gjallarhorn got to have sleep everything
sleeping shotgun there's a sleeper
looking you know hand cannon everything
looks like the sleeper simulant based on
that whole war mine more teeth and I get
you like normally I'm like yo I'm all
about the new but it's just like they've
been teasing with the with the design so
much it's like boy they don't give me
about damn sleep yeah so we're talking
about scale what you will see on screen
is what we were talking about right now
the videos out there so sorry they're
smaller but what you see in a scope is
the background image of what we're
assuming is gigantic yes sir so this
could be one of the potential worm gods
so I guess the big name that we keep
seeing thrown around yeah
it looks like it swallow us and
basically half the city whole wondering
how we ever gonna even scratch the
surface of this guy so I guess we'll see
you have if this is strike boss it's not
unfortunately gonna be the raid boss but
a damn sure looks like it should be it's
about
um but if this is like your story and
you I don't know we're gonna find out
but it definitely looks big so they
definitely this is what I was talking
about for my caries visions they're like
they wanted a big boss fete they're like
well how big can we go I think they went
pretty huge oh yeah yeah all sorts of
massive on that one so but it looks cool
you've got the facilities we're clicking
through and then you still got the
Valkyrie you've got the hive they've got
some slight differences I've heard I
noticed people were like slowly picking
through the videos like if people got
hit or slowed so they're gonna have some
frosting or Colton effects on you as d
buffs that are gonna kind of come from
this area so at least it's cool that
they're adding some different mechanics
to it so even if it's not a full
different enemy type by any means it's
high with a you know a little bit of a
nice twist
absolutely oh we're getting there but I
see how but yeah these are cool little
videos guys so check them out just get a
little preview I also talked about the
Valkyrie which is your new relic this
part of the escalation protocol and
maybe you'll get it in a mission or
something like that who knows but it is
actually a weapon literally designed by
the war mine they actually say that they
say that so it's pretty legit - they say
it's definitely cool for that slam you
can think of it as the hunter would do
the arc Strider slam Throwdown but as a
ranged weapon
it looks like a javelin filled of
dynamite it looks really cool and it's
got some solid range when you chunk that
thing yeah and the blast radius were on
the honor on the attack it's
ridiculously huge it's meant to be kind
of a beast so the repick relic probably
won't show up that often and not to cut
you to shout out to an old player ohm he
actually was there in the when they were
at the the summit and he talked about it
was so cool they spoke to the devs like
damn it's only 20 seconds it's kind of
you know you don't really get a chance
to really get all so they said that that
they told those guys at the time they
were thinking about extending it but
they wasn't sure but we
that confirmation on no Prada is video
recent video which is that it's going to
go up to it they add like another 10
seconds more last minute in the dev
update so I mean with this latest update
so that's that's a good delete that you
know even though it's last-minute a
request to feature people wanted a
little bit more time with it they're
having so much fun with yeah I mean it's
those few moments that we actually get
with cool relics like this being a sword
the shield in vault of glass those few
times we get it let us enjoy them we're
probably not gonna break your game we
might just you know kill the guys in
that little story second way but you
know 30 seconds 20 seconds let us feel
like you got a little long exactly again
not trying to play videos but we do want
to talk about them if a patch no preview
now this isn't everything fun pieces to
talk about in here
shout out to fire team chat answer
destiny Gary oh yeah it's going up to
300 watch out I have to wonder certain
questions and this is one of those where
I want to sit down with the dude who
handles it and say explain to me why 200
can't be a thousand or 500 why is it
only up to 300 now they say this is a
short-term solution they're working on
it and it's better but as we keep
getting collections if shaders aren't
fixed there are if mods are still gonna
be there until the fall it's like
they're trying to give us a little bit
of something and hopefully again these
are those steps to the fault but it's
why can't it be 400 if it's 300 is there
what limitations continue to be an issue
on that I don't know not a marker numr
of course that we all just wish it was
more we always wish it was more so I
don't know I know it was an issue from
the start yeah man yeah it's one of
those curious things that you would
think you know with d2 it was solved
from d1 and again we're now designers
we're not you know we just want to get
that dialogue as to why this seems to
still be an issue as far as to slow slow
grind with getting more space but surely
that's at least getting start man
twelve or thirteen hundred days will
finally have to get reset before he gets
a little more vault space that's not
fixed it's like you know have to start
that counter over it maybe halfway here
you don't work you but it's it's better
than it was Lots is a decent amount I
mean you've got your collection of all
the Osiris weapons so my weapons called
the new exotics all the new raid gear
yeah gear and weapons right I mean is it
gonna be just new ornaments for the raid
we'll get to that in a little bit save
that exhale Waiting to Exhale their head
so most of the multi emo wheel well
biggest update let's go this what I'm
talking about baby for days get my jiggy
with it this is what I'm talking about
people sleeping on this this is a big
deal I know I'm joking I know I'm being
silly this Motech emote is a big deal in
destiny I don't care what nobody says we
are going to be able to coordinate our
dances on the fly and what's cool is you
don't have to have a sit now right you
can swap out the sit with another emo no
crucible is gonna be lit just running
around patrols is gonna be lit just all
the things you're gonna be able to do to
communicate I'm having fun with this
it's about damn time multi emos in the
building I'm happy
oh yeah if you're missing anything I
think actually ever verse had both the
sweeper BOTS and the selfies so if you
got any bright just you want to blow
this week on an exotic emo them up
actually I got it took me forever to get
the selfie but I didn't finally
naturally get it so really I see I think
I've got the sweeper on PlayStation
mm-hmm and then I've got the mic drop
and the selfie split like I'm gonna rock
I'm rocking like it's actually a like
it's not even the legend it's like a
blue it's what he stands with his arms
crossed you got oh he's like your
guardian disagrees like he's got an
attitude and I love it it's just so
like I like knock people off the control
part and I just get that post this is my
this is my beat won't be like I'm
standing here baby they're doing a
little blip towards guided games so they
will feature a Leviathan guide emblem
attracts the number of raid encounters
and raids a player has completed as a
guide
then this emblem records rewards a
unique aura for 14 days just kind of
like they raid one does now once a week
while the aura is active a guided
guiding any raid to completion grants
one bright Engram now it's a small piece
but those are more this is a baby step
in the world of mutant if you just took
the words out of my mouth it's better
than nothing look is it great yeah
but they needed to do something so like
you just said baby step in the right
direction reward these guys man so
because you want these guys to be guides
to get people in those raids that's some
of your best content you know you got to
do something you got to do emblems you
got it you got to do rewards you got to
do stuff for these guys yep so small
step in the right direction but I feel
like they're doing a full reap I don't
come fall as well yeah can we show I
think matchmaking I mean I was listened
to between destiny community podcast
fireteam chat cardi radio like a lot of
the ones that I listen to I mean all of
us had had the same thoughts it's like
we need a reason to do guided games yes
so this is a tiny piece of that but it's
also when it comes to matchmaking don't
be afraid of it so like you take a
normal nightfall now me if I want to
solo it give me the option because
there's enough of it that do we want to
sell it but if you want to give me a
checkbox to click on matchmaking and
they'll just search it yes give us an
option press aah you can probably manage
too but at least the normal nightfall to
get your thing if you guys want to like
throw the stuff out there anyway yeah I
mean I don't know no all I want them to
do is because even because we know that
wait times have to be pretty you know so
just based on the community and you know
what's going on with the player account
you know what I want them to do and I'm
hoping this may be a big ask but what
I would love is for them to let you
queue up so you can do other in there
great yes
boom five guys are ready do you want to
fly in now you know I mean do you want
to stop what you're doing and then zoom
over there and that's what they need
because if you know we all know the play
accounts low and it's gonna take time
even when it's nice still gonna take
time to set those kind of things up and
they really have to encourage it more
and it have a system like that in place
I think would be a huge deal for them
yeah I mean no one I've heard it and
other games have it and that's like you
definitely been done before it's one of
those that would help especially if
you're like me PC is the struggle for
either competitive in a list or things
because it's a short list out there so
if you want to do competitive and grind
for this glory say I want to do that but
let me go hit a public event while I'm
waiting so yes you're something and just
and has the option there and you just
got to be able to bail at a seconds
notice but if you are good then like
okay you know and you have 30 seconds to
finish this if not you know we have
thanks oh nothing more nothing more
disheartening than sitting at a static
screen to an hour I don't know if I can
fly my ship around and play space
invaders or away fine that would still
be more entertaining but oh so they're
gonna have a new inventory category
trying to move things out as we're gonna
have all these exotic quests that we get
to go on for our masterworks they're
gonna be a pursuit category and it's for
each character not shared across the
account nice which is interesting I
guess if you start and exotic then it
will continue on that character not
really they'll take my arm
legend of Icarus prestige item that's
taking up my hair inventory for the
longest okay I want that thing out of it
hopefully it goes into that category it
should at least I think I thought I
heard that somewhere yeah random in-game
audio settings the weekly lock outs for
the raid and raid lair are now
class-based interesting just run it
three times on a warlock and max out
your warlock now used to it wouldn't
matter more
because you were trying to get your
warlock armor but yeah if you're running
for a tight and you're getting tighten
arm you may be able to get the weapons
but not the armor so interesting that's
a big deal yeah I could do all those you
know multiple character guys you're
gonna have to play without characters
you ain't gonna be able to level boost a
guy up and they've done that and then
what was the other thing with the exotic
farming I like it - sounds like take the
cheat not avoid like exactly let's go
yeah that was one of the things that's
like I mean be a world World of Warcraft
like people didn't even finish the first
raid boss when it opened up much was the
other ten that were behind it I mean you
had mister of 40 person raid it took
hard enough for you to get the group
together then you would down a pause and
lie to three people a year and you would
do that over and over to build up part
of your group you finally got back
before then you start getting to pieces
like yep it was work to get there but
when you finally shut up yeah that was
literally my channel five day but we did
a rapid machine the first day I mean we
will probably have no business being in
here based on the light level initially
cuz we didn't get a chance to grind as
much as most all of us most of us
couldn't but um it just felt good as you
know you'd be certain sections and you
got traps that really helps your light
level made you play it again and again
and again you know yeah I do like I
still missed that it's like hey I know
if I'm looking for the helm it's coming
off the final boss certain sections
dropping certain things like in you know
you want that run I mean they were
trying to get away from checkpoints and
rotate everything but I was like make a
progression like I know it's like a if I
if I work through this first section may
not being agreeing or at least that
boosted my level some like yep guys love
it
they said the fixed issue were
collections where event emblems would
not show up and played and less players
on pairs of Osiris fix a black screen in
the tower which I have seen I've also
seen people not load just I think a PC
issue sometimes - okay - offering one
treasure map for mercury he's been doing
that for a while if mercury shows up so
at least
back to 3 that'll be nice video this
week was like I didn't even end up doing
it I was like I'll do it then I looked
there's one I was like well this seems
stupid yeah they said Bungie will
release the patch notes shortly before
their target about 10 a.m. for the
release of the patch notes 11:00 a.m.
Pacific time for the actual expansion so
bad an hour before definitely watch the
world of Bungie and Twitter if you don't
fall Bungie on Twitter and Dylan and
Cosmo and deed on Twitter do it that's
how you'll know when that stuff crops
mm-hmm next we got the details on some
design action john-boy sniewski is back
my man so after another lengthy update
he's like gonna keep it somewhat short
but we got risk earner first if you want
to take the details yeah so pretty much
my boy
I love when was new ski gets in the
building because I get to talk sandbox
and meta which I like so pretty much
he's talking about the risk one of the
art conductors they increased the
resistance to the incoming arc damage
but said it's pretty big enabled it in
the crucible that's gonna be interesting
you know saying cuz I want to see how
that plays against you damn Titan
strikers yes basically will activate
when the weapon is stole which is a huge
deal but damage resistance will only
work when the weapon is in yeah so
that's fair and this date said it's
already strung on for PvE well hoping
these changes will give it in place
interesting conclusive loadout
strategies and counter so obviously it
has some footage of that below so again
a nice little touch you know I think
that's gonna be very very underrated
there's gonna be some cool builds I
think people will come up with you know
based on reducing that uh that damage so
I can't wait yeah it's pretty cool like
I haven't used it that much I mean I
kind of feel like it says you said a
fairly underutilized gun so if they can
get it into a place where it it has a
spot for a certain piece there's no loop
that was like as you say for like a
Titan slam it's like is it gonna be too
tight and slam if it's next to you yeah
probably not
if it does that'd be kind of crazy it'll
be crazy but we'll have to see
I think they're getting crazy with stuff
like you know attract again and I mean
this thing about that crazy for fun
police
oh my god is fun police like certified
that is subtle another hunter it's over
it's over it's like do you know how the
arrogance people gonna have when you're
they people charge at them with their
super and it's like please not that turn
that off like I always felt like a
hunter for you guys one of the most
disrespectful supers is the the nice
trucks [ __ ] because I'm coming at you
there's like no stop that and you're
like boom if that hits you in a normal
match it's brutal I love debuffs and I
like that with the route that they go
risk runner gets it I don't know if
it'll be tractor cannon worthy board I
will test it out put it through the
paces yes a doubt the Dustin Luger with
a vault space and tractor cannon man you
should be happy for at least a couple of
days we got sweet business now something
is going on with this gun and you were
saying it's an exotic causing him to
continually get ammo back yes I've got
confirmation and also shot it's my boy
unknown player he also confirmed what I
said the reason why in this video it is
appearing like he is shooting limitless
bullets but he's the warlock he's
running Luna faction boots so basically
how that works it's kind of like they
put you put the riff down and when you
step out the rift and you step back in
it kind of working like a Titan shooting
rally barricade yeah so it's the same
effect so what he's doing if you look
closely when the video plays is he
strafing you know from side to side
that's how he's getting it but what they
did is they increase the reserves which
is cool I mean the more the merrier 999
ammo so beasty if you can get that
combination together between rally
barricade or warlock one again hunters
I'm sorry guys I got screwed
yes between those here I got a wall or I
got well ultra reloads it's like you
only get to do that little you know spin
around once and yeah I don't know I
don't know what the answer is for honor
I know they're their own thing but feel
like they got the shortened into class
item he uh but yeah they fire for
however long this video clip is thirty
seconds they basically don't quit I'll
turn the audio down but it just
constantly goes here and he's also like
getting like plus 66 he's getting some
ammo back in the magazine yes there was
that be actually exotic doing that um
I'm not sure because it's like the I
mean what if far as in the magazine yes
no excuse me
Lulla faction does do that yeah in the
magazine that's gonna faction all the
way yeah I just wish I could just stay
in it like that's been moving back and
forth I gotta jump in and cuz you know I
thought it was gonna be a dope exotic
for arms for Africa Alice some like oh I
could put this one play I can help the
team and it's like no you got to step
out you step in you can't step off the
plate rift off to one side and be off
and on the other its coordination you
just like I said I that's not to digress
but I can't wait for exotic armor master
works because yes these are the kind of
things that just need slight tweaking
and I can't wait to see what they cook
up because I'm loving what they're doing
what exotic weapon master works so this
got me excited for the future actually
the summer it's not gonna be too long
Sammis summer when we get the exact
master works with bounties master work
is for sweet business mmm I meant to say
the armor which go of what you call the
reworks oh no I know I know what you're
talking about a month saying in general
is like we're sitting here looking at
sweet business what do you think the
best work is on this one Oh what do you
think it is no I mean generally it's
either one or two things either they
change the the they actually make a perk
where it's you know they actually
changed the behavior of the gun right or
it's just some tremendous that boosts to
the gun
um I don't know this is a big this is a
pretty powerful exotic yeah I can't
remember if it was on the list of them
not changing or not actually I don't
know but I mean everything is eventually
gonna get an exotic masterwork so I was
like what is this option I've no idea I
have no idea my gut says with business
that maybe they don't do they kind of do
coz cold heart for my understanding
doesn't get like a newport cold heart
just gets like these crazy stat bumps
right yeah whatever sigh my gut tells me
maybe with this cuz they just kind of do
the same you know boys like it's yeah
they're trying to probably not make it
too epic yeah Lucy I think Darcy just
got a little better whoa so poor Darcy
sniper rifle now grants four times
damage once locked onto a target and
they say exact scaling depends on
activity difficulty late little yadda
yadda but it shouldn't take a master
strategist to figure out how this will
benefit you in PvE any crucible combat
snipers also want to give this gonna try
seven in the magazine or news room
closer engagements they said the aim is
that aim assist at has been retuned to
be more generous when you have a locked
on a target so yeah it already gave
precision damage increased before now
you're talking about a four times damage
was locked meant Darcy could be scary
like you're gonna start melting some
bosses mmm-hmm they're showing it on at
Argos here in this clip mm-hmm he gets
out and he dumps I mean he goes 32 and
then he's locked on hitting 56
continuously I'm hike that is insane oh
yeah if you wanna boss if you like your
snipers and if you've got Darcy hold
onto it in your inventory look at port
for a Basra and it's gonna be a good
thing so I'm thinking about Darcy vs.
canvas - oh man so some of these changes
are gonna be nice and just make us feel
more powerful for 3:35 we go fight
Calais or our ghost
lower-level raids mm-hmm I feel like I
should start melting some phases should
be should be feeling a little better
mm-hmm yeah I think he just kind of
shouts out the team and I was like this
is he's got a blip he's gonna take time
to say hey this is not a solo act you
may hear from me but shouting up the
whole team the testers everybody doing
some good work so they they care about
the people there so bunchy still doing
some good things absolutely
now we get some mix things up a little
bit this is all you this is so you guys
but I started like he's gotta be good
crazy oh man when it comes to strikes
they said heroic modifiers are coming
back and also the nightfall challenge
cards we knew were like 0.9 aka still
beta phase so they've made some changes
to heroic strike modifiers and also what
you can do to what you pick for your
nightfall challenge mm-hmm
we've got some variety no I like the way
they did this even more than before
tires for d1 heroics and be like okay
they're in there they're not all in
there
but they have enough variety and
hopefully they add more but this is the
method of it I will say there are more
modifiers I think probably do you want
but the method I like they take the
heroic strike will have three modifiers
one burn it will rotate weekly so be an
arc singe or void that's gonna rotate
once a week so you still know what
weapons you're gonna go with but then
they're gonna have one advantage in one
disadvantage that rotates daily so
you'll know what guns you want to run
with but you're gonna have a different
fight depending on when you fight it
during the week or the burn options we
know just kind of like the nightfall
arcs engine void 25% increased damage
both incoming and outgoing and so you're
taking more but you're given more so
getting on the strike you may note you
may see like and different strikes have
different you know stuff that you're
gonna fight you may have a solar singe
and you go into a strike that's gonna be
the arms dealer and you're like oh god
but then if you do solar Sinjin you go
fight something like Sabbath and song
that's a little more hive it may not be
quite as bad so
definitely gonna be interesting
sometimes maybe easier
heroics still probably are not gonna
break you they never aren't at nightfall
level we're just giving you a little
more variety to these at least to
something I may step into and match back
with and be like eh let's see how this
feels this week no it also gives me
something to cover in my weekly resets
speaking of longer videos have also got
to figure out what the first bought the
first boss is as high as quickly as
possible if anybody can get to rank
seven for escalation protocol because
it's a rotating so your daily advantages
of one of three things brawlers back so
double melee a recharge rate and damage
so don't punch some faces on to punch
Grenadier regreted here either way you
want to say that one it's probably the
second double grenade ability recharge
and damage no your those pulse grenades
can start shocking really
you went there now the one that will got
me kind of excited this is the date the
first time this pops I want to play
triple power ammo drop rate double power
weapon damage I want to see a rocket
just like just melt that same hour think
about something like a linear fusion
rifle mm-hmm good about merciless
disgusted one guy and get triple power
like you go do the probabilities now you
get to that section you're gonna melt
him so fast you do like three supers
it's heather unload merciless that last
room is gonna be done in about ten
seconds you're gonna have some heavy
weight or some heroic speedruns with
heavy weight oh yeah justice yeah
disgusting is a good way to say that now
on the other hand you've also got a
disadvantage though this is where you
like you're getting interesting fun
police
and now they get a battle I gotta keep
it balanced they can't give you heavy
weight and not have something to keep
you in check so we've got now they
rotate
daily now there's three advantage of
four disadvantage so
they're not always gonna be the same
rotation so keep that in mind we've got
glass playerhealth and shields are
halved so be a bit a little bit more
glass cannon type but recharge rates are
doubled so it's like a I'm a I'm a more
fragile slightly mayhem type person yeah
oh that one's kind of cool so that one
kind of gives you a buff if you can play
safe but if you get a slight on the
wrong singe
you're done you're done but now these
are always match made so it won't be
quite as bad but and just keep this in
mind
nightfall is coming next yeah and this
is where I'm gonna start crying because
I'm probably gonna die
blackout radar is disabled what was that
call to d1
well no lights which is the second half
after the calm I haven't got there yet
I'm trying to remember what was chef I
forget the names now yeah but there was
one anyone were just radar was the sake
check it was it Jolie chef right okay
it's Jeff I think either way the other
part of the comma that had me like
because light switches back from d1
enemies do 20 times increase male like
I'm just thinking of like balls
oh yeah and yeah thralls
mainly you don't get into as much but if
anything even touch it yeah but if
you're in a hive strike you may not want
to put a blackout on that one you just
be like nope we're going back to orbit
so you guys yep see mom but no I
remember light switch before that was
brutal and they let the lights out we've
got iron is your next modifier enemies
no longer staggered that's ice but
that's me back yeah I forget what it's
called as like ironclad I think or
something cool or how pools are
increased by 50% mm-hmm that's gonna be
definitely a longer burn longer yeah yep
but if you have something like heavy
weight that's probably good balance out
a little bit and then finally grounded
players take five
damaged while airborne some of these
values are a bit steep I think very very
button you're done yes so I guess I will
not be a Dom bleed that strike yeah
that'd be dicey you picked off out of
the air yeah you own the ground
throw hammers or shoot lasers so pretty
much uh yeah so but I mean this is this
is what we've been asking for why the
stuff took nine months to get here it's
made also I mean May June July August
September fine eight months eight months
to get modifiers bust and we still
missing not to be debbie downer this is
great we badly played it we've got it
we still need now heroic strike rewards'
how about that you know how about giving
us a reason to go through this hell we
can play man if it's like brawler yet
it's black out good luck
come on so we'll see hopefully in time
and again I'm hoping and crossing
fingers and again if this isn't it for
you right now remember there's always
the future have fun enjoy what you like
to do but I'm hoping these types of
things are what setting up the fall
facts I can't implement fall everything
at a time they want to get things out
get them tested getting more cups aim
thing with the life nightfall challenge
cards which we got now yep
so nightfall challenge cards are
changing as well for one you can take
your rare challenge card your blue one
and go desert they gave him something
else to do
we talked about the bayou and literally
they regimen you need him to do
something else it's a baby it's a baby
like yeah these are baby steps but you
can take a desert upgraded to a
legendary challenge cart doing so adds
more customization options to the card
mm-hmm and I like the fact that I see
nightfall modifiers and the extinguish
is not required yes because for me that
was kind of from if I want to work on
points and say I get to the boss fight
and say I've got 60,000 you can still
keep knocking them down but if I get to
the boss fight and I want the challenge
to let me turn it on but give me the
option to turn it off as like trying
practice at least nygren like if you're
gonna get if extinguishes gonna give you
another like a whole 1x multiplier above
that I understand it's a risk but give
me the option to turn it off so this is
a good thing alone I saw that in the
thing seems good but you can have let me
read this right just so I get it right
so you're gonna add more customization
options you can add you can select one
burn one advantage one disadvantage and
two additional disadvantages mmm
so that's also gonna crank your points
up you can also change the difficulty of
the strike as well now do you know what
is it 45 points or something like that
insane so yeah you're gonna see some
high points and if you get the team's
putting these runs together they've got
a lot of ways to mix this up which is
cool mmm I figured you'll be excited for
this tie like this is the Evod section
it's a hard solo thing to do on some of
the stuff in the soil again so Terry's
gonna like he's gonna make me look
terrible but she is gonna enjoy this I
think more than anybody else so looking
forward to seeing what he can do but
I'll try and get up there in my little
piddly like 2x multiply 5.5 everything's
on extinguish mm-hmm it's gonna be
interesting like it's fine you can pick
you can choose you can have a little fun
to bring in a few of them back they said
except with the exception of glass which
is the one where you're half health but
recharge rates so like on a fragile
mayhem all other advantages and
disadvantages list above from heroic
strikes can be applied to the challenge
chart so glasses the only ones not I
kind of wonder why there's just one
glass in that damn I mean you have 20x
damage done basically lights which I'm
not sure why I have health in general is
gonna be rough but yeah maybe they
figured it was too much if you one shot
by like I'm yeah if I did some testing
mm-hmm there's a few disadvantages that
are unique to night falls as well you've
got extinguished it's just back we know
about that one you've got famine ammo
drop rates reduced by 50% why is that in
there yeah that's just
oh that's just it
you got like you have bread in there
that they don't even tell us in there
like that was a modifier before enjoyers
literally in the game I saw yeah
somebody tested yeah like 66 percent of
the time it's it's literally live so
they've gotta fix it it's just
frustrating it's like ice
I'm usually my scout rifle the whole
time I switch over to one hand cannon
then three scout rifle you know unity
weapon boxes pop out and I'm it really
really that's I just had to shoot one
hive guy over here with my hand cannon
match game is back so players must match
their damage type to enemy shield types
life hello-hello hard light if you got
borealis but I think hard lights gonna
be a big one there so if you're running
that one you want to use that as your
extra modifier just run with hard like
you're good to go go
attrition not a huge fan of this one the
last time I literally said the same
thing you just said literally yep those
are the two heating surprises yeah
health or Jenna's greatly slowed so you
have to just hide and cover longer
enemies drop the little health Lords
with it get you going but man it takes
it's brutal and there's a lot to get
going yeah it says health regenerates
only when the player is moving at least
they fixed the description because
they're like oh it's like you won't your
generate health when you're not moving
it's like no you have to be running for
like as long as it's a chance to do a
shoulder charge like yes to regenerate
it so yeah you got to be moving but if
you want to have some fun and crank up
the challenge mmm I gave you an option
so and they give you more of a chance to
get the knife for strike roll it right
yeah speaking of nightfall strike
rewards'
they boosted the scores yeah thanks for
your prestige being what it was before
20 40 60 80 30 61 200 yeah you now get
the Beast emblem mm-hmm
at 200k putting in some work because
they're about to fix the lost sector
thing as well mmm-hmm that's right so
they're not gonna be yeah shooters you
can't cheat and do the farm you're gonna
have to crank up some modifiers the
difficulty turn everything
on and just go yeah fax yeah so I'm
gonna have some people these people go
and you know Johnny Hopkins back up on
the top again he's on the last week he's
right there on number three so he's
definitely working on it so these guys
put in the work
notice two out of three pound signs in
there yes sir
that's that PC action something else but
people are somewhat confused about it's
a little weird
what's going on with the airbrush man
break it down simple John's like let you
take this one for a second I'm still
trying to make sense of it it just
sounds like okay yeah we have all of our
stuff we're trying to make it easier to
acquire converse because people were
complaining you know that they can't
have a direct route to what they want
you go the vibe I'm getting now is that
this gives people more control of how
they earn items well for a more
particular path and then they say drop
through a duplicate items so from my
understanding there's this present but
now just in prismatic drop try to look
for that named prismatic pantry
yeah the matrix but there's also this
thing called a facet that I believe that
once you know yeah yeah you get it you
get it to drop
then you that guarantees you to select
you know that the item that you want
from the matrix you can explain right
here prismatic I said yeah yeah mm-hmm
so I released the prismatic matrix will
feature ten ever verse items from season
three each week it is active each item
within the prismatic matrix is on a
knock out list so if you play a lot in
one week and you get your new matrix
from ever verse for the week or whatever
and you start getting those experience
you know illuminated engrams or whatever
they might know as you play in level up
you're gonna be knocking stuff off each
week now next week it may change like
you get an ornament over here something
like that but you guys can see it looks
like an exotic ship looks like an
ornament so these operating like a faded
Engram sort of speak sort of
you don't get the same thing yeah it
seems like that and it's gonna change
every week so but it's gonna be on a
knock out list if you get one then
you'll get another and just seems like
kind of a random chunk that you can work
towards each week if you like if you
know there's a week there's an emote
that you really really want mm-hmm then
it seems like the more things you do
within the week it says the current
connections expire in four days 21 hours
mm-hmm if you grind and you can get ten
or ten levels of worth of experience
then you have a chance to get all 10
things in this box basically so it's a
way if you have something you want to
grind for in Everest you could put some
effort in that we can go for a certain
thing mm-hmm
also they mentioned so with your first
well-rested level of each week you'll
earn a prismatic facet around one free
use of the matrix so basically it's just
a free tick of that box yeah prismatic
factor facet stack up to three so make
sure you have proper inventory space
before earning a ring cup each given
week you have three of them and you're
saving them be like hey I don't really
need anything this week hold onto a
couple before next week get the new one
be like hey this is it here
one drop three facets real quick and
then you can you know see if you get
that new thing or if you got to grind
some more so it kind of simplifies some
of the grinding to the rack if you're
going for ten things as opposed to all
of that reverse if there's one emote
you're going for you can grind or put
some work in for that and if you really
want to 200 silver you can buy another
activation I mean for max oh I don't
know what mm silver is what does I don't
even know that conversion rate sorry I
forget but I mean if you had ten slots
in there you wanted to get ten punches
you know you could at least knock out
your whole matrix so instead of going
for random exotic random engrams or
things like that you have a chance for a
more specific so again pretty much like
I knew you would explain it better than
that with it pretty much like a direct
path to a better direct path to the test
at reverse item that you really want so
that you know you kind of get on get on
track with it which is cool it kind of
lemonade
less of the randomization aspect yeah
they also mentioned right here ever
verse we'll have a few more things so 14
items now up to 18 items so I don't know
what those additional four are going to
be and Adam emotes on deck because I'm
ready
you know a lot more people using them so
they want to just continue in evolving
ever verse and I think this is an OK
thing it's not a bad thing gives you a
reason that grind for you get a freebie
each week though I mean you'll still
probably get your hand grams so outside
of the prismatic matrix players will
continue to run bright engrams each time
they level up so you're still gonna get
stuff from ever verse just a normal but
this is if you have a specific grind you
can work towards something a little more
focused so positive step in the right
direction based on all the negativity of
ever so gotta get him some cross release
attending to implement this yeah they're
trying
I mean its cosmetics none of this is
real and that's what always ticked me
off about ever versus oh it's all locked
behind them like it doesn't affect the
gameplay yeah that's like if I'm playing
god of war and I can go buy like the
ultimate acts like for money yeah that's
gonna break the game none of this stuff
ever broke the game none of a little
token thing so typically was an
overreaction me but the fact that
they're like just give you more direct
pass that's good stuff so here's our
server maintenance times and your file
sizes nice you know we're still breaking
the bank because they unload it twice
but yeah 6 a.m. server Maness is
scheduled to begin mm-hmm in activities
at 7 a.m. Pacific are booted boot you
know it will be available to download in
install 7:00 a.m. on Tuesday morning
will be 9:00 a.m. I'm gonna need to like
see my wife can turn my playstation on
and on and then 11:00 a.m. so 1:00 p.m.
for me to pay him for you after your now
get up and get on yes sir I don't think
one hour longer nap we can lose play in
chat level but you know
absolutely they know about a few issues
actually for the patch as well mm say
anti extinction grieves the female
Titans that orbital egg or Appice rain a
visual thing works um like a crap what's
wrong fast work
an exotic weapon or armor piece will not
display a masterwork when viewed from
the exotic in-game preview I'm like oh
okay that's nice
strike playlists players not able to
match back into the strikes from an
expansion they don't own that actually
makes sense
give you a prompt if you don't own it
you know there's no need a rematch make
war mind some quest items from the
campaign may not show up in the loot
stream for all fire team members but you
should still get it so I'll hop on the
side of your screen may not be there
yeah
exotic armor tooltips maybe in a
different color doesn't mean you can't
use it just little little daring minor
glitch but respect to transparency you
know but yeah it's like we know these
are an issue
Tenzing saw them we're not gonna have
them fixed quite yet they don't really
affect anything nature at all and we're
not delaying the DLC for it thank you
nope yep so you got some videos of the
week as usual and as you guys know it
goes live so switching from pages mm-hm
we've got basically Bungie took their
website and split things into two
because people were confused what season
three what's the expansion what's what
so they've got the war mind page which
is basically everything with the
expansion you guys know what's the story
so we're gonna have the new story the
campaign in that piece that is a big one
you can train in a brave the Guardian
thought to be lost searching for her
past what's beneath the polar ice caps
of Mars on the developer insight to come
for that yes sir
now one thing we have not talked about
quite as much is the escalation protocol
at least this week and then we talking
about it last week
mm-hm but that's another piece you
obviously can't get to Mars if you don't
have the expansion just trying to let
you guys know what is gonna be available
season 3 crucible maps are actually
gonna be out there which is a really
nice there's not divided playlists which
should help I didn't even
I feel real stupid boy cuz I go into
Crusoe all the time but I never click on
the damn Osiris thing when I go
QuickPlay yeah I've never did either it
so bad I never did either I'm like I'm
sitting there I'm like I don't see the
new maps yeah yeah I never click on I
mean usually I'm like seeing more
information where that's what's usually
bringing me in it but if I had to
randomly do a quick play I just click
the big one button so that's gone thank
God good but that's season stuff but for
the expansion war mind you got the
escalation protocol now though we've got
a few details about escalation protocol
if you guys want to check out the
PlayStation Blog article about it's just
got a few cool pictures it is actually
cool to see the knight with a shield
yeah doesn't like frosty shield here
cement-covered snow theme I mean it does
look like they took say snow if item
yeah but there's actually a couple
pictures here so you can see the hive
sword is back mm-hmm smack in the ground
always sounded so good so I'm looking
for it but they don't know a little bit
of detail about their inspirations for
it there are two main areas where you
can activate it in Hellas Basin they're
gonna work similarly there's different
areas in like the means like of each
major section where things are gonna be
spawned and you have to use the whole
section so whether one's up on a hill or
ones down in a valley or ones behind the
corner whatever it is you're gonna have
different kind of encounters for each
piece of the fight so I have you moving
around and there's two major areas to do
it now they describe this is and
something they wanted to make sure was
difficult if you start out and you go
through and you're like okay cool I
finished the campaign I'm 340 I'm at the
soft cap let me go see if I can knock
out level 7 I just got killed ya know
you're probably gonna get worked at
first now nine people together and you
have like everybody sit together and be
like okay let's wait till one more
person walks over here we're gonna try
this it still might get killed but it
could be an attempt that might have
and if you start to level up local
difficulty bump definitely gonna be
rough
they said it's somewhere between because
they said core Dvorak's was literally
boss challenges how do you fight this
boss in this tiny little area okay you
figured out the boss fight and you're
good and they also said our cops fortune
on the other hand was kind of a [ __ ]
desk mode people would come in waves
then you have the final thing in the end
they had prison of elders they say which
is ritual which is that basically just
the public event on Titan release oh
yeah so I don't know why they mention
that specifically but I guess that's
kind of a piece that might be involved
in this as well but they had pieces from
all over the place and they say like
well lower level players be able to hop
in technically yes yes Jake forty and
you're walking around now if you have
three people out there to like 381 three
two and you're walking up at three forty
they may be able to do it they may
appreciate your peashooter boats cuz
you're doing a little bit of damage
probably not gonna be doing as much so
escalation protocol as you get higher
into those levels it's gonna kick your
butt so just be ready for this thing to
be not an easy thing when you get to it
that's probably the biggest takeaway it
does look cool so I mean strategies
events to get there basically they say
three max levels so three 83-85 three
players should be able to do this with
well with good coordination it's
possible yes what is definitely gonna be
a struggle so if a couple more people
show up you're probably gonna be happy
they did mm-hmm
absolutely I like it man difficult
activity I'm liking it man and the final
piece about that we do have the rotating
bosses so I know somebody is gonna be
trying to get to seven just to see who
boss one is and a cool thing we're not
gonna know not everybody's even gonna be
able to see boss seven on day one much
less rent one because it's not like four
hours later hey alright I maxed out
let's go check this out I might get to
fifty cuz the rate drops Friday yeah
that's right it's rising literally right
there boom boom but I mean even between
all your all your milestone upgrades
your powerful engrams and the raid I
don't think there's enough grinding
you're gonna be able to get like I doubt
anybody breaks 370 I agree they're not
jumping
I hope they don't I guess I hope nobody
breaks 370 in week one I would love to
see that I'd love to see it take longer
mm-hmm so just know that this will be
out there for you guys try not to read
into much in depth when it's on
PlayStation Blog but they just go a
little more of an interview with Bungie
yeah I just kind of jump it into it so
just the rotating boxes would be cool
the grind will be cool kicking your butt
will be kind of funny so kind of cool
raid lair so they do talk about the
spire of stars and everybody's like
what's fire this one right up here no
six come back to the lava
nettie think this thing will be somehow
hive themed no I take that back there
maybe because they kind of did that with
the last one eater of worlds right they
had they might have some have enemies in
it a night um you know I'm just looking
for the conclusion of the counter store
and I want a proper conclusion since I'm
stuck here let's conclude this the right
way you know I let okay so what if it is
not related to the expansion at all I'm
fine with that is the wrap-up of calais
and the Leviathan and some property and
I'm fine with that
only caveat if we get like some cool
cinematics and cool story you know I
want an aurochs like completion to it
like I don't want a cliffhanger for all
this you know I really want a good a
good conclusion for all the time
investment and then after we do all that
no more raid lairs ever again reasonably
that'd be great we'll just I'm wondering
if you picture a spire the way this
thing looks like it could be on a city
is that like you know callous penthouses
are not callous yeah countless
penthouses you're a pair going up to
knock out on his office door and be like
hey we're finishing this I'm done I'm
done with your stuff because I also want
to know like what if those ships are
callous like he's actually going to
grace us with his presence you know once
we complete that thing or whatever
and you know when we before the robot on
a puzzle and the other little mini rat
layers why do you stare isn't gonna be
something that's like not a big fight
what if it's a jumping across ship so I
could finally go face Calais in the end
conclusion with it would be nice if the
narrative would wrap up because
disconnecting this game it kind of sucks
some of the life out of it it just does
it does it completely does so I'm cool
you know with I understand I've accepted
my fate it's not gonna be anything warm
and related but have a nice little warm
mind logo literally right here on the
bottom but you know not giving the hopes
too high for the raid layer which is
really sad to say this is not what's
appealing to me it's like no okay so you
know we got the expansion for taking
King and the new rate yeah that was that
was what I would wait for him but no
matter how much facts I could - gotcha I
was like not curse another eight not
exotics not anything I'm more excited
about exotic masterworks
this is a sign of what's been broken so
much exactly dhadak masterworks knew
exactly works and crucible is what I'm
so hyped for I'm like okay wait later
okay you know I'm like you know I'm not
even that exact about it but I mean
we're gonna do we'll see it would be
cool if we're pleasantly surprised right
if we're pleasantly surprised by the
story if we're pleasantly surprised by
this raid you know what was yeah I just
hope it's a nice conclusion I would like
baby give me two boys you know yeah wrap
this thing up let's come down let him
explain what the true power is you know
something give me something
it'd be nice so crossing fingers maybe
they got some words out there maybe they
listened but we'll see doesn't need to
expansion launch was made
good stuff yes sir Oh season three on
the other side this is where you heiped
oh let's now you talking my language now
this little gift right here mm-hmm I was
putting together so you got sky burners
launching up there messing people up
good old hand cannon I can tell it good
times so with the war mind which is your
paid expansion
everybody gets season three stuff mm-hmm
so you've got exotic stuff you've got
ranked crucible modes you've got two new
maps private matches which I still wish
were custom I'll say that until it
happens
I mean it's great for tournaments if you
want to set up tournaments it is the way
that needs to be there to happen
those tournament people who want to
experiment get creative or just goofer
and it's like do you want to be in a
match with me where it's literally
snipers only you can only use Darcy and
we're gonna map together what do you
let's do four out and have some fun
that's where I will play private matches
is when there's a reason to be like hey
let's get a couple of the iron Lords on
there let's get twitch I'll put up lied
be like hey we're gonna try out some
goofy modes let's go let's go mm-hmm
emote vault space again thank you so
look like we got some picture of some
exotics here so we got Sturm and Drang
SunShot is apparently they haven't
talked about it basically they're just
saying it's more of what it already does
so if it explodes it explodes bigger I
think you got sky burners nobody's seen
anything about prospector we've seen
guiding what is that gun fighting line
hiding lying I was like guys I don't
know if I'm gonna start with it but I'm
definitely gonna do that question I'm
dying what does a master we're gonna do
on this good that has been a laughing
stock that's BT right and let's be
honest even in the new reveal you're
like yeah I don't like they don't look
like that matter and then when it was in
the video if it was doing the explosive
damage for like a hundred I'm like if
you want to create lunch in a matter
majeure I can't talk sir if you want a
grenade launcher to matter
that's singly they had a hell of a lot
harder if not be a one shot that really
does some more play like close like one
round in the in there and maybe like two
or three get to reload but colony is
brutal like you think you match that
closely one shot yes look what do mean
I'm like because my man Lord West new
ski I love you but when I was showing
that fighting lion revamp footage
like shadow to PI Rho into T it's like
what what it's like anything you're like
uh-huh what what's happening I don't I
don't think nobody died no I did not
that was not the kill they're like oh
yeah crank it up guy I was like can you
look at prospectors like so prospectors
the one that hold the fire released a
detonate all grades live simultaneously
so if you get a clip of like eight in
there you load up a point and then go
explode mm-hmm I mean nobody uses at
those cuz again they don't matter they
need to hit like a truck I want to load
up wait hold it down I love to have like
an infinite hold and then not have like
giant look like visual cues they're just
waiting for a detonation somebody walks
onto the point release yeah just like
you know or set them up as like
proximity just you know line up a
doorway somebody walks around BAM
yeah low-key and I want prospector and
fighting lying to have like some Opie
perk that you unlock this is like oh
okay like they still suck yeah otherwise
they'd be right back in the world hard
light sweet business restaurant a rat
King it looks like this is probably the
exotics that are gonna change
yeah he's always gonna now masterworks I
don't know if these are gonna be the
master works or just the changes not all
are giving you messed works at first
right eventually oh that's true but that
is true but they did I think everyone on
this list they've kind of talked about
in a master
work fashion right racking we talk I
mean the only two that I know no you're
right you're absolutely right
vigilant swing and tells the other one
that changes a property
crimson crimson zeros in five hundred
range which is crazy by the way that
thing will be interesting but we sorted
this just a boost
remember okay that maybe the other one
from a picture that's it so but again
they're not all so yeah you're right
these are getting boost maybe others are
getting master I don't know so yes I got
some questions to see everybody's just
gonna go into the the tower and stare at
their and it's Dara damnit re and like
alright what am i doing first where's
the catalyst is the catalyst ready yet
no so we've got crucible or emblems
which kind of cool he's about to take
off like a spaceship just certainly that
looks like an emblem that looks like
it's yeah but you got valor up top you
got a four-wheeler more this is your
grind and glory
catch it last time get yourself up to
rank of fabled world of glory which is
they say about 40% of people get up
there go up a little bit before you go I
know you wanna registrate now fable
would be the third yeah maybe I was like
you have to probably pick it up first
there were five total hold on I have two
computer monitors so I can look at last
week all day yeah I'm curious yeah so
cold heart you see exotic masterwork
it's taken stability to like ninety
reload speed probably up to about fifty
and that was just defeat enemies that's
the catalyst sorry Guardian guardian as
I guess basic we've got brave heroic
fabled mythic and legend so I guess the
ardent of Bureau and wanted yeah
so in a second what's the next one so
brave mm-hmm
heroic mm-hmm fabled so fabled is the
one with the sword icon the first one
with the sword icon okay switch that
there okay
yeah that's my thinking legend getting
the getting the afterburner thrusters
than the big olive branch so yeah yeah I
mean those are cool
now like I'm hoping the background of
these emblems of this background should
be absolutely insane yes please make it
crazy please yeah explain more is gonna
be good we got two new maps we got
basically both are gonna be on Mars
looks like coal of a spray for one as we
said above ground in the facility below
ground in your ice tunnels horn outside
or something
matches the only difference is if you
want to use the new maps and private
matches you have to buy the expansion
but yeah it's like there's some maps I
don't even see him that often like what
is this yeah yeah what okay so we know
them I know that map that's he wants to
I feel like yes I know no a neces map
that looks like this and you've never
seen that we don't know about I mean
lately yeah yeah learn something new
when you're doing a stream about
something you're supposed to know about
that that's it guys so wraps up a lot
we've got a lot coming so you've got an
eraser
campaign how many missions you think I
would say maybe six five or six
[Laughter]
I mean for me they think eating was
eight I'd like that but I don't think
yeah I don't think this is a still of
medium sized expansion I would call it
now let me caveat this if there are five
they better not be the strikes yeah
mission three and four or four and five
I forget they better not be just the
copy of the strike again making a real
strike yes I played though I played the
story missions more by running night
falls than I ever have going back to
type a Korra that's a good boy enough
solo killing myself over and over I
played that mission more times than I
ever did the story so facts war mine
mmm-hmm also including crucible what is
your what's the first thing you do
what's your first hour oh just for this
asset II I have to do story like I have
to know what's my first things I do in
crucible okay that's fair point so you
finished the original campaign what's
next oh okay okay um I'll run escalation
for call I'll run it just to see see
yeah just see the mechanics see if I get
killed but I'll be honest like once that
story's done I am racing across whoa I'm
gone for the glory I need the glory
I need him and then I think what my
chances are good because like I think
this like that all the sweat ease cuz
half the sweat ease are gonna awesome me
playing the game as well so I think the
earlier I get it me to better I got I'm
gonna do the campaign next month I'm
gonna start in crucible right now
good level increases in there with you a
bit you know you never know so I'll be
I'm gonna be in definitely but uh I got
a do story I got a complete you know
that kind of stuff
uh you don't touch escalation for a
little bit you know I'm gonna be living
in that crucible man and um I will say
this I will also be you know I'll be
dusting I'm or did it now like I'm using
a destiny item manager I'm dusting off a
lot of these we worked um exotics I'm
literally I have like the tractor cannon
in there I've got you know I got no oh
yeah I got or sabe be graviton Lance is
ready man I got that ready I got Rat
King wrath what I'm looking forward to I
think graviton is one that I will
probably actually use a lot Molland yeah
sky burners yes that one
I'm gonna try Rat King in escalation
protocol scene that I can actually see
it being really beneficial yes if enough
people have it equipped and you at least
getting three you guys around that I can
actually see being good I didn't even
think about that I'm gonna have final
building yeah I mean stuff like ward
cliff isn't gonna change mercilessness
I'm gonna change much now if they master
work those I still eventually they're
all gonna get master works I'm like yes
what the hell is the word cliff coil
master work play honestly the thing our
team gets one rocket but if it's in
remotely in the region in front of you
it's done yeah what's your master work
an extra bullet in the magazine just
because it's just oh no I know one of
them should be should be a make sure it
hit the damn chandeliers and array like
it used to I'm excited for that I'm
excited to see which ones get them
excited to see the ones that do get them
how the boundaries are gonna work you
know what's the questline just messing
around like you know what type of
activities they're gonna make us do to
get certain ones you know something's
gonna be heroic strikes maybe someone be
crucible
we'll be fine man yeah those heroic
strike daily modifiers it's gonna be hmm
gonna hurt and just I'm curious about
the secrets you know what do they young
yeah what do we get please give me
something to chase let me give me a few
collectibles I'm spending time I got a
war literally not for collectibles but
there's a reason I'm going for a random
chest cuz they're silver and I want to
pick it up I go find I I spend the time
to figure out a puzzle I wish they would
put puzzles with the game cuz even just
the little puzzles you've probably done
enough have you done any of the puzzles
really hit the free oh yeah they get
more annoying later because I have some
fun videos or I probably look really
stupid in my video I'm like you gotta
hit him right or be at the right angle
or figure out what order and it's just
like they're not even a hard as possible
once you get it you're like just little
pieces to be like do these three things
and then this little tiny collectible
comes out of the ground you can do that
best me like you shoot three targets or
shoot him in order or be like so here's
this thing you got like little stuff
like that would be nice
even the bells in the banner now that
you took it back you took it back to
fill with to speak so that type of stuff
but I mean for me yeah it's campaign I'm
gonna want to do some glory but me I'm
gonna be granting me some masterworks
cuz that one it's gonna be my quest I
want like graviton one sky burners
because you gotta we gotta unlock the
full potential I want a hard life master
work PvE melton nightfall what you're
right that bastard actually I'm gonna
change it up yeah I think I'm doing that
same more I got a grind those master
works after their stories yeah I mean
it'd be a good way to balance some pay
maybe you need to go kill Guardians with
one of them and that's part of it
hopefully hopefully one is actually PvP
related that's how I say hopefully a bit
of exit I feel like sure I'll do that
all day oh yeah I'm just gonna cure it
I mean Oliver Game Master works
but no somebody's gonna be scary like a
masterwork Telesto just bigger clip more
range mm-hmm some of actually change the
like behavior of the gun vigilant swings
to behave oh speaking of which did you
see that skin oh oh yeah I was like I
love the old Egypt going on it I like
this skin we've got now the ornament but
whatever I saw a new one summer I was
like okay that looks better
yeah Jade rabbit
Oh does it get any love it has to right
no I'm looking at like I'm switching
between because I have different exotics
on different consoles I'm lightening it
can't wait man it's coming fire that's
gonna be a good time so we got we got
some stuff to look forward to if you
guys can't tell we're optimistic is it
gonna be the perfect thing that fixes it
if you're done playing pub G right now
and you want to gettin by the expansion
in the first place what I tell you to
buy it next week let us tell you on
Friday see if it's anything good exact
but honestly for those of you if you
have the expansion and you still have
that H in the back your mind you're like
oh it's just me what's a little better
this has things that are gonna give you
hope for the future
absolutely this this is these are the
baby steps in the right direction and
still meaty enough this way if you love
destiny and you're scared that this is
gonna be a curse of Osiris think I'm
pretty confident to say it's not I'm
pretty confident saying that this is
gonna be way better than that now is it
gonna be like you said the earth
changing the whole you know communities
back hybrid DLC probably not and I'm
saying but this is definitely step in
the right direction and it said they
laying that groundwork for September
with these kind of systems so I can't
okay excited and you listen to us next
weekend we'll break it down our
experiences you'll be playing as much as
I can between work and it's just gonna
be not a lot of sleep and a whole lot of
time in here so absolutely I'll probably
be streaming a decent amount of that I'm
not sure what the night falls gonna go
up to so a solo nightfall or run seems
normal might be manageable but solo
procedures gonna be like gonna be a
little bit I think
each one of those even esoterics like I
just I just can't get there and he's
like he's probably gonna probably find
some way to do it anyway like yo he's
like no I'm not I'm too good the
difference oh yeah honestly for
everybody out there it's like if you got
the expansion I suggest come to check it
out now so I think the campaign is gonna
be like epic game-changing
no but curse of Osiris set a really low
bar so they should yeah the crap out of
that is it gonna be taking keen
continuity full probably not I don't
think that's gonna be a the again till
the fall till we have a reason unless
like you know Gauls dad comes into town
or something like if you want continuity
like then you need something bigger but
hopefully it's the space Doritos I heard
EFT say that on the DCP podcast I
literally I don't like lol but yeah
better if we - he's hilarious you've got
some definite beard love there - it's
all a beard but and he's got the voice
of he's got a small vibrator yeah those
guys are maybe you got some pipes I'm
like I am none blessed with the radio
big Barry Manilow love going on there
Doritos was like come on please bring
back the space Doritos I've never heard
that I was like that's perfect I can't
not think of them that way now I do
doubt that's what they think will you
see them now that's the fun it was like
next time they do the reveal their like
oh but guys we tried to get it started
sooner but we knew it was gonna be a
long point for that exact reason our and
43 minutes on my stream so yeah it's
been a good one hopefully you guys enjoy
enjoy your weekend wrap up anything else
you want to have some fun and iron
banner me I'm gonna try and divide my
time between some iron banner just cuz
it's fun
sixes feel pretty good in Bojana more is
I got a try and wrap it man I got at
least get through water out
smart you got your priorities right me
I'm vanity like I'm broken I'm screwed
up I got to get that up I am banished
season two chestpiece melees and
grenades all day so if I'm not gonna get
my 40 percent I don't think I can get
there you can throw it you just gotta
ground but you got got a voice with that
you have a two and you chose not to yeah
because my OCD I didn't know I didn't
have this thing that I need hats thing
is what I really want to do before all
these game-changing things happen I need
to grind my hunter up to about 3:30 so
it's like if I character cuz on I have
two on each I've already made for this
was going for a fifth one when it was
just previously I was like I don't agree
in the story for like the fifth time so
I took a break but now that things are
gonna change it can it harder to level
up I'm like ah but everybody out there
guys thank you for tuning in I know my
side it was very quiet but as always
thank you guys for everything the
support the following anybody who tunes
in on Twitch every view on YouTube every
comment we thank you guys as always we
try and read and listen to all of them
thank you to everybody it's a fund what
we do it's for fun hopefully it'll come
back to a time where more people are
excited about it to the world yeah I
mean I have no idea where anybody or
everybody's watching this or will on
youtube so whether it's good morning
good afternoon good evening I don't know
midnight snack time whatever yes hey we
got those night hours come on yes have a
good one guys enjoy your weekend and
can't wait for Tuesday that's right
we're on the eve baby even a warm I have
a good boy